- I didn't even really
like business, honestly.
- Really?
- I really didn't.
That was boring to me.
But I had an idea, and I
had a dream, and I thought
people need this product.
You have to be driven,
you have to be motivated,
you have to have passion,
you have to be somebody, who,
like I said there are no noes.
If you want to start your own business,
you really need to put in
the time and dedication.
And that means 24/7, if need be.
If you really have a drive
and you really put your
heart and soul into something
you can really make anything happen.
- She's an American
inventor, entrepreneur,
and TV personality.
She's best known as the cast
member on the reality TV show,
Shark Tank.
She has helped launched over 400 products,
and holds 120 foreign and U.S. patents.
She's Lori Greiner,
and here's my take on her
top 10 rules for success.
Also guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
on the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
by your sharing and also
when you write it down,
you're much more likely to
lock it in for yourself too.
Enjoy.
(introduction music)
- I just had an idea, I was
always thinking of things,
I was always creative,
and had no plan, in which,
to make products or be an inventor.
I didn't even really
like business, honestly.
- Really?
- I really didn't.
That was boring to me.
But I had an idea, and I had a dream,
and I thought people need this product.
And I got the bug, and
once you get the bug,
and you realize you can do it,
then you just keep doing
more and more and more.
- 'Cause you want
so much--
- It's infectious.
- Yeah it is, and you
don't really want to stop.
It's like you ...
There's never really, like, an ...
You think there's an end goal,
but then you always know there's
something more to be done.
Or, buyers at stores, for me it was the,
you know, TV shopping world.
- For me
it's like,
- Queen of QVC.
- Yeah, queen of QVC.
- [Interviewer] Right here.
- Once you have a successful product,
and women, for me that was
the audience at the time,
women loved it.
Then you want to keep pleasing,
you want to keep creating things that
make them happy.
- Right.
- That make their lives better,
and, you get personal gratification,
but then you also know that
you're helping other people
in their lives.
So, that for me was quite infectious.
I just wanted to keep doing,
and making more,
and it became easier and easier.
'Cause I knew what I was doing.
- I'm a woman in business, so are you--
- [Lori] That's right.
- And it's great because
they're different personalities,
successful, be yourself,
take care of business.
- Be yourself.
- Go for it.
- Yes.
- Get out there,
but it can be bumpy along the way.
Any regrets or mistakes that
you feel you've kind of hit
through the years.
- Well, you know, I share
certain bumps that I've had
in the book.
I think that, you know, I
don't like to look back,
there are no mistakes
really, everything is a
learning lesson.
- Everything helps you to do better.
- Right.
- So I talk about some of
the mistakes that I made,
and it just helps you
to get further along,
learn from those mistakes,
and get smarter.
My entrepreneurial spirit flourished
when I started thinking of ideas,
and then seeing them
out there on the market.
But I hadn't done that,
someone else had.
They were very successful.
So when I thought of my
earring organizer, I thought,
this time I'm going to do it, and I did.
I knew that women had no good way,
in which, to store their jewelry.
And it just came to me,
like a thunderbolt, and I
went home and I drew it,
and then I went to my
grandfather's wood shop,
and I made it.
After I made my sample,
I did market research to see
if people would really like it,
or buy it.
I started calling every
retailer in the country,
let it ring a thousand
times until they'd pick up,
and I flew myself to 21 cities in 18 days
and met with different buyers
and showed them my prototype.
That first product was very successful.
I made well over a million dollars on it.
And, I started thinking,
wow there's lot's of other
things that I could make.
And I started making cosmetic organizers,
I started doing kitchen gadgets.
My goal was to improve people's lives
with the products that I created.
To date, I've created over 400 products,
and I've generated half
a billion in sales.
To me,
an entrepreneur is somebody
who will do whatever it takes.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- They're driven, they
are A-type personalities.
They,
it's like they don't know the word no.
And that's always been my mantra.
I know no noes, just, how can I?
So,
when I see that person I
know that no matter what,
even if they have to pivot, you know,
which is something that happens.
Maybe this isn't the best idea,
but something else is and
you're going to change it,
they're still going to make it,
because they have what it takes
to be a successful entrepreneur.
- [Kudlow] New business
formations are way down.
- Way down.
- [Kudlow] Way down, and
venture capital is way down.
- Well ...
- That means people are
afraid of something.
These are brand new business start-ups,
a very important economic measure.
Way down.
- Well I think, to me,
I'm an entrepreneur,
and I think that true entrepreneurs,
it doesn't really matter
what's going on in the economy.
If they come up with a great
business idea, great product,
they're risk takers,
they're going to go for it.
It doesn't matter if the taxes are up 5%,
it doesn't matter what
is going on with that,
they are people that just are pioneers,
they're going to forge ahead,
and start that business no matter what.
Well, I've launched, in the last 16 years,
400 new products.
And I have a 115 patents.
- People going through this
now have a lot of options.
You have fund-raising
cites like Kickstarter,
you have little online
market places like Etsy.
Do you recommend that people use these
to sort of test out their products?
- I think a lot of people
don't trust their gut enough.
I think a lot of people want somebody
to hold their hand through the process.
And really, that's not the best way.
There's no special formula that's right
for every single person.
You have to decide, do
you like Kickstarter,
do you feel that's right for you.
Or, you know, people have other
ways in which to do things.
So I think it's know your options.
- It's got to feel good when
someone brings you a new idea.
- Well I love it.
I mean, that's what drives me.
- I love the excitement
of taking a product
and turning it into a huge success.
So, you know, that's what
Shark Tank's all about,
and that's what my book is all about.
It's exciting!
- What are some of the key traits
to being a successful inventor?
- Well, I think definitely,
you have to be driven,
you have to be motivated,
you have to have passion,
you have to be somebody, who,
like I said there are no noes.
You know, if I have an obstacle,
I go over it, I go under
it, I go around it.
- Right.
- You just don't quit.
- I go through it!
(audience claps)
- Well, I think that start-ups should,
one, be willing to do
everything that it takes
to make their start-up work.
You know, a lot of people
say, "Oh, well, you know,
"I just want to do it
for a few hours a day."
(chuckling)
That's not going to happen.
If you want to start your own business,
you really need to put in
the time and dedication
and that means 24/7, if need be.
Make sure whatever your idea
is that people really want it,
and need it.
And the way to learn that is
to do some market research.
Don't just ask friends and family.
Get out there and ask a lot of people,
and a variety of people.
If they like your idea,
and if they would buy it,
use it, or pay for it.
And if so, what would
they be willing to pay.
Make sure that you've
done all of your research,
and what it takes to get
your product idea out there.
So, have a business plan,
and find out all the steps required first,
so that you're not missing
anything along the way,
and you don't mess anything up.
Make sure that you learn
all the people that you
can market your product to.
Stores, shopping channels, whatever it is,
make sure that you know them,
and that you're aggressive,
and you're very
enthusiastic and passionate
about your product idea or business
because your enthusiasm
becomes infectious.
If you believe in yourself, they will too.
If you really have a drive,
and really put your heart
and soul into something,
you can really make anything happen.
I'm a true believer in that.
So,
I think that we,
hopefully, we make people
believe that they can achieve
the American dream too.
Just watch, study us, and
if you really are passionate
and driven you can get there.
My true feeling is this.
No matter who you are,
no matter what age you are,
no matter the time in your life,
if you have a dream,
and you have the drive,
you can make anything happen.
And if you are ever feeling down,
or feeling like you
can't get over that hump,
or you just have a bad day,
I play this song
and you remember this song, okay?
Here it goes.
♫ This girl is on fire
(audience claps)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
ohworldgirl asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next
leave it down at the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
And I'd also love to know,
what did you learned from Lori today
that had the biggest impact on you?
What was your favorite clip, and why?
And what are you going to
take from today's video
and immediately apply,
somehow, to your life
or to your business?
Leave it down at the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Bli Dodi.
Thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
and posting that picture online.
It really really really means a lot to me
and I hope you're
enjoying the book as well.
So, thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.